as we can see in the background the  shells the shows that this is definitely  from palestine and they burnt this part  of the quran but guess what part  has survived and look what it says and  one of the pages from  surah baqarah 211 says ask the children  the children of israel how many clear  signs we have given them  and whoever trades allah's favor after  receiving it for disbelief  should know that allah is indeed severe  in punishment  and the next page in 214 the page reads  do you think you will be admitted into  paradise without being tested like those  before you  they were afflicted with suffering and  adversity and was so vitally shaken that  even the messenger and the believers  with him cried out  when will allah's help come indeed  allah's help is always near